Carbon compounds rule the globe!
They are present in almost all bits and pieces
that we can see, touch, or smell!
However, when we say “HYDROCARBONS”, what
does it exactly mean?
Yes!
In literal terms, we mean compounds made up
of
Carbon and Hydrogen.
But tell me one thing…
Are all the carbon compounds only
made up of carbon and hydrogen?
Are there no other atoms that makeup the
compounds?
If all the compounds will have only hydrogen
and carbon, then every
compound should have the same or similar properties
right?
But that does not happen!
We see a wide variety of properties in the
carbon
compounds because elements other than carbon
and hydrogen can also be
present in them.
This gets us to the concept of Functional
Groups!
Now what could this mean?
Let
us understand this concept in a simple manner
by splitting the terms.
The word
GROUPS mean a collection.
That indicates a collection of atoms.
And Functional
means having an important role or function!
This tells us that the functional group is
a group of atoms that have an extremely
important role in the FUNCTIONALITY of the
compound that they are present in.
Yes!
Say there is a random compound WXYZ which
is attached to the functional
group AB.
In this case, the properties of this entire
compound are majorly
determined by the functional group AB.
There’s another way in which we can
understand functional groups.
They are defined as the group of atoms which
have definite properties.
These functional groups impart the properties
to the
compound in which they are present.
The presence of functional groups defines
the properties irrespective of the length
of the principal chain of carbon or side
chains attached to it.
Do we know a few examples of functional groups?
Of course we do!
You must have come across the terms “Alcohols”,
“Aldehydes”, “Ketones”,
“Phenols” and so on!
These are nothing but functional groups!
So let us say we take a carbon chain of ten
carbon units.
The carbon chain may be
a straight chain or branched one.
Say it has an alcoholic functional group attached
to it.
This was the case of saturated hydrocarbons.
Same holds true for unsaturated
hydrocarbons as well.
Now in any case the properties of the compound
formed will depend on two
factors!
First factor is the presence or absence of
single, double or triple covalent bonds
between the carbon atoms.
It means the compound being saturated or
unsaturated will define many of its reactions.
Another important influencing factor is the
presence of a functional group.
It is
this group that gives the characteristic properties
to the compound formed.
Now let us have a look at a few more examples
of functional groups along with
their structures in the upcoming videos!